il ya un problème spécifique de nos
communautés et tout le monde ment pour
sortir en contre des maires alors tu
n'aimes à zizou kenza la télé j'étais
trop classe sa soeur on va lui trouver
un vrai bonhomme un mec qui sort à la
mater ce jour rien et kenza boukamache
représenté par son frère chérif acceptez
vous de prendre pour les poules elle
racontera va jusque royal à quenza c'est
ma cousine elle est 100% halal ça c'est
pas le ghb
elle parle tout comme ça là bas les
sites excité et je vais te dire à ces
dix boucles il est que les poulets les
charbons qui l'écouteront
comme un trait mariale
ça se passe bien à 12 heures et après la
double attaque le bel ou là
hello vasseur voilà je la connais qu'une
telle éventualité grave
j'habite en france et j'adore comment
j'allais réussir
la propriété parce que tu m'as sauvé que
ça donne des droits sur moi
oh
soit pas trop kiffé toi l'égalité des
hommes et des femmes à gala pour inna
alcoolique indiqué